من دواعي سروري يا جنرال ميلي أن
أشكرك راي أقدر الفرصة التي أتيحت لي
للتواجد هنا كم من الوقت قبل أن تتقاعد
كرئيس لهيئة الأركان المشتركة أه بعد
بضعة أسابيع فقط الآن، لقد تقاعدت بموجب القانون في
منتصف ليل يوم 30 واه إذن ما هو
ذلك 18 19 يومًا  شيء من هذا القبيل
أم، وبعد ذلك ما هو أول شيء
ستفعله بشكل جيد يا زوجتي وسأنقلك
خارج مجموعتنا السكنية في فورت
ماير حيث أنوي النوم والتخلص من
الأكياس تحت العينين وأكون  أفضل
جد، يمكنني أن أكون على ما
يرام، دعنا ننتقل مباشرة إلى الأمر. يقول الكثير
من الأشخاص على الجانب الأوكراني الذين
تحدثت إليهم الأسبوع الماضي عندما كنت في كييف،
إننا لا نفهم أننا نطلب هذه
الأسلحة،
دعنا نقول المريخ العالي والغربي
تقول الولايات المتحدة لا لا لا، ثم
أعطتهم لنا أخيرًا،
ولكن بعد مرور ثمانية أو تسعة أشهر
نشعر أن نفس الشيء
يحدث مع التاكومز، نفس الشيء
يحدث مع طائرات إف-16 إذا كنت
ستعطيهم  لنا لماذا لا نعطيهم
لنا بسرعة
حسنًا أعتقد أنك تعلم خلال
الفترة الزمنية التي قدمنا ​​لهم فيها
قدرًا كبيرًا من أه من
المساعدات العسكرية تبلغ قيمتها حوالي 40 مليار دولار حتى
الآن أه وهناك أكثر من 100 مليار
دولار إجمالي المساعدات إذا  لقد قمت بتضمين
المساعدات النقدية والإنسانية، لذلك هذه هي
الولايات المتحدة فقط، لقد
كانت الولايات المتحدة سخية للغاية، لم
تفعل ذلك ولكن السؤال هو إذا كنت تريدهم
أن يفوزوا بالسرعة، فلماذا لا تفعل ذلك بسرعة، نعم،
فالسؤال هو السرعة، وهناك
مشكلات ميكانيكية هناك  من حيث مدى
السرعة التي يمكنك أه مارشال هذه المعدات
ومدى السرعة التي يمكنك بها الحصول عليها عبر
خطوط الاتصال من أه
الدول المجاورة ومن ثم مدى السرعة التي
يمكنهم استيعابها لذلك لا يقتصر الأمر على
رش الغبار السحري وتبدأ الأشياء في
الظهور  شيء آخر هو الحاجة لذلك في
بداية هذه الحرب
كانت الحاجة الكبرى للأسلحة المضادة للدروع على سبيل
المثال لوقف الهجوم الروسي
وهذا ما حصلوا عليه وبعد ذلك عندما
تحولوا إلى ما هي
العملية الحالية كانت حاجتهم هي دبابات فهود
برادلي أه  احصل على قطع غيار من هذا
النوع أه كما تعلم
مركبات ميكانيكية ومدرعة من مختلف الأنواع وكان
الغرب سخيًا جدًا في
توفيرها ومن ثم يجب أن يكون لديك
التدريب اللازم لمرافقتها
وقطع غيار الذخائر التي تتوافق
مع تلك الأشياء لذا كل شيء
يستغرق القيام بذلك فترة من الوقت، إنها
ليست مسألة آه، كما تعلم، كل ذلك
يظهر مرة واحدة، ما رأيك
في الوضع الحالي
للهجوم المضاد، هل تعتقد أن
الأوكرانيين بدأوا الآن في الدفع ولكن
حسنًا، أعتقد أنهم كانوا يقومون بذلك بشكل
متسق تمامًا منذ
الصيف الماضي، كان الشتاء كثيرًا من
القتال ولكن لم يكن هناك الكثير من الحركة،
ثم كان هذا الهجوم على الرغم من أنه أبطأ مما
توقعه المخططون، فقد كان
ثابتًا  وقد أحرزوا
تقدمًا مطردًا من خلال هذه الأحزمة الدفاعية المتنوعة
وقاتلوا بقوة في
باكموت وقاتلوا في دوناسكين
وبالطبع إنهم يقاتلون بالقرب
من مثير للشهوة الجنسية في الأسفل
باتجاه ميلاتوبو وماريوبول وكل ذلك
لقد كان تقدمًا مطردًا، ما
قلته منذ أشهر هو أنه سيكون
طويلًا وصعبًا ودمويًا لأن طبيعة
هذه المعركة تحديدًا أه ثم
ونوع الدفاع الذي
قدمه الروس وقدرات
الأوكرانيين تبشر بفترة طويلة جدًا
معركة صعبة للغاية وطويلة لكن
الأوكرانيين كانوا يفعلون أن
لديهم الكثير من القوة القتالية المتبقية،
فالأوكرانيون ليسوا قوة مستهلكة
وهناك طقس كافٍ
يسمح لهم بمواصلة
تحقيق تقدمهم المطرد،
ولم يفشلوا، أعلم أن هناك بعض  هناك
تعليق يقول إن هذا
الهجوم قد فشل بطريقة ما، ولم يفشل، إنه
على الأقل النجاح الجزئي الرئيسي الذي
حققوه بالفعل من خلال العديد من هذه
الأحزمة ولديهم وقت متبقي لذلك سنرى إلى
أين سيصل الأمر لكن الأوكرانيين
أظهروا  قدرة لا تصدق
من الشجاعة والمرونة والصلابة وهم
يعملون ببطء ولكن بثبات في الطريق
عبر بعض الدفاعات الروسية الصعبة للغاية،
لذا فإن الهدف الواقعي الذي
يعتقد الكثيرون أنه يجب على أوكرانيا أن
تمتلكه هو في الأساس الوصول إلى
كوفاسوف للتوجه إلى الجنوب
ماريو  قم بوضع تلك المنطقة بحيث
تحرر أوديسا كميناء يمكنهم
بعد ذلك البدء بحرية في تصدير جميع
حبوبهم منك، نعتقد أن هذا
ممكن، حسنًا، سنرى
أعتقد أنه آه
لا أريد أن أقوم بالتنبؤ
بهذا الأمر فقط  ومع ذلك سنرى ما سيحدث
أه مرة أخرى هذا أه أكثر من 200 ألف
جندي روسي أه في أوكرانيا المحتلة من قبل روسيا أه
هذا الهجوم أه رغم
أهميته له أهداف تشغيلية وتكتيكية
أه محدودة
بمعنى أنهم لا يفعلون ذلك حتى لو كانوا  لقد
تحققوا بالكامل، فهم لم
يطردوا كل الروس تمامًا وهو
الهدف الاستراتيجي الأوسع الذي
كان لدى الرئيس زيلينسكي والذي سيستغرق
وقتًا طويلاً للقيام بذلك، وسيتطلب ذلك
جهدًا كبيرًا للغاية على مدار
فترة طويلة من الوقت.
لا أريد أن أضع وقتًا محددًا
لذلك لأن الكثير من الأشياء يمكن أن تحدث
في الحرب، وهي عبارة عن رد فعل رد فعل مضاد، يمكنك أن
ترى
انهيارًا عامًا، يمكنك أن ترى تصعيدًا،
يمكنك أن ترى الكثير من الأشياء المختلفة
تحدث في المستقبل ولكني  يمكنني أن أخبرك
أن الأمر سيستغرق
وقتا طويلا لإخراج جميع
القوات الروسية البالغ عددها 200 ألف جندي أو أكثر عسكريا من
أوكرانيا التي تحتلها روسيا، وهذا هدف
مرتفع للغاية، وسوف يستغرق الأمر
وقتا طويلا للقيام بذلك،
هناك هدف محدد  اتهام في حقك
أدلى به كبير موظفي الرئيس السابق
مارك ميدوز أه وهو يقول أن
هناك هذه المذكرة من أربع صفحات أه
خطة هجوم للهجوم على الولايات المتحدة
لمهاجمة العراق إيران أه ترامب نفسه
تحدث عن هذا هذا المشهور المشهور
الوثيقة التي كان يلوح
بها لكن ميدوز يوجه الاتهام
بأنك كنت تضغط على الرئيس ترامب
لمهاجمة إيران. هناك تقارير أخرى
تقول في الواقع إن ترامب هو الذي كان
يضغط عليك، ما هو البيان الدقيق،
خائف جدًا من النظر إليه، سيكون الأمر كذلك للغاية.
من غير المناسب بالنسبة لي أن أعلق على
أي شيء يخضع لتحقيق فيدرالي حالي،
لذا لن أفعل ذلك، لكن دعني
أقول هذا كرئيس أو أي
عضو في John Chiefs، مهمتنا هي
تقديم المشورة، لدينا خطط لجميع
أنواع الأشياء و  عندما نقدم
النصيحة عادةً، نقول مسار
العمل واحدًا أو اثنين أو ثلاثة نتحدث عن
التكاليف والمخاطر ونقدم
توصيات ويمكنني أن أؤكد لك
أنه ليس مرة واحدة إذا أوصيت
بمهاجمة إيران
هل سترد على ذلك بهذه الطريقة  ريد
اعتقدت أنه كان ملفتًا للنظر في الواقع
اعتقدت أنه آه لقد ذهب إلى ما هو أبعد قليلاً مما
قاله إنه سيذهب كما تعلم أنه قال
أنني لن أعلق على هذا
ولكن من الواضح أنه أزعجه بدرجة كافية
لدرجة أنه قرر ذلك  للتعليق عليه على
أي حال وبقدر ما أستطيع أن أقول
كان ذلك نهائيًا جدًا أه لقد
ادعى ترامب مرارًا وتكرارًا وكما تقول في
تلك المحادثات التي أجراها مع
أه مع أشخاص ليس لديهم أي فئة
لا تعرفها أه تصاريح أمنية أه تلك
المشتركة  الرؤساء
يضطهدونه ميلي بشكل خاص لمهاجمته
ولكن هذه كانت خطة هجوم لأي شخص
كتب مارك ميدوز أنه في مقدمة
مذكراته ويعطيها
مكانة مرموقة، فهو البيان الافتتاحي لرئيس
أركان الرئيس
ويقول ميلي بشكل قاطع أن ذلك فعل
لم يحدث ذلك، تجدر الإشارة إلى
أنه على حق، وكان ميلي على حق عندما قال إن
لديهم خططًا هجومية لكل شيء، فالولايات
المتحدة لديها حقًا
خطط لجميع أنواع الطوارئ، لكنه
كان حاسمًا جدًا في أنه لم يفعل ذلك
في أي وقت من الأوقات على الإطلاق  أوصت بأن تقوم
الولايات المتحدة بغزو
إيران
الخارجية